c'est à nos confrères du bien public que
la revendication a été envoyée elle est
arrivée sous la forme d'un message audio
ses auteurs un mystérieux commando de
défense du peuple et de la patrie
française inconnue des services de
police et qui revendique une filiation
avec le terroriste norvégien anders
breivik
trois personnes avaient été blessées
lors de ces attaques au marteau qui
avait eu lieu à proximité du boulevard
mansart à dijon
l'assaillant avait alors réussi à
prendre la fuite depuis aucune
revendication
pour la justice le message envoyé à nos
confrères est une première piste mais
elle est à prendre avec précaution cette
revendication semble un peu étonnante
puisqu'elle intervient plusieurs
semaines après les faits elle fait état
de raisons qui seraient des raisons
essentiellement de lutte contre et
d'agressions de
l'encontre du multiculturalisme de toute
façon une enquête précise est en cours
et va continuer pour savoir si il s'agit
ou non d'une revendications fantaisistes
fantaisistes ou pas ce sera aux hommes
de la police judiciaire de dijon en
charge de l enquête de le dire